as like as someone who doesn't really
have time to play games i like if
something's not like a nine or a 10 i
very rarely go out and play unless i'm
streaming it or making content or
something like that but how would you
know if it's a 9 or a 10 if you don't
play it um normally i just watch reviews
and watch and listen to recommendations
i don't know if you've heard of
something called ign
but uh i i go on a thing called a
metacritic obviously obviously the most
trustable most trustworthy basically the
only game gone has ever played is
ocarina of time
it is a light novel there as well so
that might get you into it yeah there's
a lot of darkness never shut the [ __ ] up
there's a lot of dialogue it's really
weird because it's like it takes me a
lot to get into a game sometimes it's
like like i try i've tried to really
like narrow down what my taste in video
games is and the more i think about it
the more i'm just like i have no idea
because like okay so like with with
final fantasy 14 for example
like so i was playing that like a little
here and there during like
uh during when i was ill right and i
remember literally yesterday literally
yesterday right we were in the lift and
i turned to terry i'm like joey got to
be honest with you started final fantasy
14 right but you don't need to worry
joey i'm like it's it's not it's not
addicting at all like i'm i'm i'm i'm
i'm like i'm like i i've played it i've
stopped myself i'm good i'm good at it
right
i shook his hand and everything too yeah
he she shook my hand um and then i went
home and i'm just like uh i don't really
have anything to do maybe i'll just like
like because the thing is it's just a
nice comfort game for me to like zone
out and just you know tap buttons um and
then so i booted up and then i get into
like my first like big boss battle like
big raids and then i remember finishing
the finishing the raid i was like
oh no
that was really fun
that was that was really [ __ ] fun i
need you to i want to take back that
handshake i gave you that night because
i thought i thought we had like
established something you know there was
a there was a trust that was formed
there and he just ripped it away i was
just like oh i really really want to
continue playing now i look at the clock
i'm like it's midnight and we got a
trash chase recording in the morning i'm
like i go for another two hours okay
another hour or two i can squeeze how
much sleep do i need and like because
here here's the thing i've never like
i've i never really got into mmos right
and i never i never went through a phase
where i got addicted to roon uh
runescape craft i was gonna say
runecraft then runescape or wow yeah
like that so this is like my first
proper
mmo and like i wasn't really into it
because i thought like i didn't really
enjoy the gameplay because like the the
battle system for final fantasy
especially at the beginning was like
really [ __ ] basic it's like just
point at something and tap a button and
do like a basic three-hit combo and then
that's it and i was like you know i'm
here for the story i'm gonna stick here
for the story but uh then i experienced
the first raid i was like
you know that was pretty damn fun um and
i'm scared for myself now i don't know i
don't know i just i just it's been a
while since i've had the experience of
just having a moment in a game and just
having like this like i guess like it
felt like a like a like an ember had
been lit just like i want to experience
that again that's what i'm saying man
like mmos are a lot like like like
quicksand yeah where it's like the more
you try to quit the more you just get
sucked in yeah i'm glad i got it out of
me when i was like yeah
i don't really have an urge to play mmos
at all
yeah i mean like what what did you guys
find addicting about mmos when you got
into it i think the number one thing
that got me addicted which i'm glad you
haven't experienced yet per se is when
you have like a large group of friends
that you see often who also play out
where like it's just like like i had
like a group of like three or four mates
like during the runescape hero and or
like the maple story here that i could
just like ring up on skype and just be
like all right so uh sesh for like seven
hours and like yeah yeah let's do it and
then you just play it while you're in a
conversation and it's the the best way
to kill time
but at the same time it's like you
finish that seven hour session and
you're like
what have i just done
yeah i think it's a game where like the
goals or for me at least felt like they
were
uh
there's
never
a never-ending supply of goals yeah
mm-hmm whereas in like a game like i
don't know if i if i do the
campaign in a card or something yeah i'm
done in there now yeah yeah but
runescape just like never ended yeah and
every time i i hit a milestone i got
more cool quests i could do wow that's
so sick oh i got this really badass item
okay and so like every time you're
you're grinding towards something you
always just kind of unlock these cool
things that were just enough serotonin
boost to keep you being like invested a
lot yeah and even when you finish
through like all those side quests for
example
you see one player that just walks past
your play and you go i want what he has
yeah how do i get that and then now your
quest is to be that yeah exactly right
it just never ends yeah right and then
also like i don't know if you can do
this in final fantasy but in runescape
you could lose like all your stuff
really yeah you could just lose yeah
escape by dying yeah by getting killed
by dying
[ __ ] i've died a [ __ ] time i've not lost
nothing so thank you see there you go
that's fine i don't know i i don't see
mmo i i've got in your hand i feel like
i couldn't i wouldn't be able to get
into like runescape a while then because
like one of the big factors i feel like
into video games is like i need a i need
a reason to keep playing and most of
that reason is storyline like gameplay
loop a lot of the time that's not enough
of a reason to keep me invested in me
invested in the game for like long term
um having said that you're thinking
about the mates thing like when i was
when i was doing this boss battle i was
like
i wonder how fun this would be with
friends to do it at the same time you're
gonna do that you're gonna be that guy
who like can't join us today because he
has a raid or something yeah yeah he has
an event raid that's only available
during these hours
um but yeah i mean this is this is i
guess the start of i don't know what
yeah it just maybe i might stream it who
knows you know how before you were
saying that like uh viewers of trash
taste could tell when we record these
episodes based on my hair yeah now
they're going to be able to tell based
on the size of his eye bags
that are going to be forming from
endless knights of final fantasy 14.
it's like it's like oh man they're like
this far down now it's like you finished
three raids
i think i also stay away from them
because my little brother was like
addicted to world of warcraft yeah yeah
right and i could like just see how much
he would play it
and to like no avail yeah exactly at the
end of it he was just like yeah it
wasn't that fun
after like years of playing yeah well of
course it's like it's like you know
every [ __ ] league player or like
overwatch player that invests way too
much time into this one game and of
course what do you have to show for it
well you know i reached diamond you know
usually usually what you have to show
for it can be summed up in one sentence
yeah it's like yeah it was fun why is it
that playing like a hundred games for 10
hours is like cena's okay but playing
one game for a thousand hours is like no
double standards right societies we live
in a society
we live in a society
that ain't right
i don't know because i just feel like
there are just so many games nowadays
that are available even if like you have
nothing to even even if you feel like
you have nothing to play or no big
releases have come out then you just go
through your [ __ ] steam library right
my steam library is like my god i have
not touched my steam like i think that's
what i think to myself right i'm like
okay so i just finished this game yeah
when i finished 30 incentives for
example yeah i was like alright cool i
finished that game
[ __ ] now do i now what do i want to play
normally people will be like oh i have a
[ __ ] like 300 games on my steam that i
haven't even like installed at all nope
instead i go to the playstation store i
download the sona 3 nocturne
[Laughter]
and i was like yeah let's play this
and now i'm now i'm just playing that oh
my god see i i would rather have one
game that i'm really into than a hundred
games that i mildly enjoyed yeah you
know like to to me like like i pokemon
rcs for example it seems like kind of
fun but it doesn't seem like a game that
i could like properly like throw myself
into you know it's it's it's it's weird
for me because i'd rather be like fully
invested in just like emotionally
invested in
one like a few things why final fantasy
why did that get you
because i heard from every person who
[ __ ] talks about final fantasy that
has a good story
to be fair as much as i heard about like
nfts are great if you just listen to
nftv rules
you know if you're asking addicts why
something's great it's probably not a
good like did you talk to people who
played it and didn't like it
well okay
there's the catch everyone who's played
it has said it's a good game
it's just it's just like for example
like when i played the trial when it
first came out i'll admit it's a great
[ __ ] game
but i i like used a hundred percent of
my brain power to be like you want it i
know it's a fun game brain
but you're not going to play it i feel
like if you're only talking to people
who are into it oh they seem to all like
it yeah cause they're into it yeah but
that's the thing everyone at least
around me that i know that has or is
playing 14 has said nothing but good
things about it yeah i feel like i feel
like there are some people who are like
maybe you know people who are for
example addicted to league or addicted
to overwatch where they're like no just
don't get into it uh it's a it is it is
not a you don't have fun with this game
you're in
you know every game has its life life
graph right yeah yeah final fantasy is
justin it's like it's infancy compared
to league we have like 15 years or no 10
plus years of league of don't do it
don't do it we know
the time has proven us
history has taught us well 14 at this
rate might also get to that point yeah
look look i i don't know if this will be
a poorly aged thing but i'm in for the
story and once i die i do the story i
just i won't really have any other
reasons
they're always coming out with another
expansion it doesn't end
well like you know
is that that is that microsoft
transactions isn't it uh is it
i haven't seen any is that is it micro
transactions for expansion well over
costumes yeah like oh okay yeah yeah i
mean it's a japanese game of course this
microsoft transaction but like you i
form what i understand you pay for like
any new expansion which is basically
like another part of the storyline so i
mean wow was the same as well right
what you had to you had to pay for
expansions was a subscription service
yeah it was a monthly plus you had to
pay for expansions right yeah and now
you have to pay for points or something
yeah i mean yeah
i don't know i don't know too much about
the mmo world um that's why i play
gotcha where i can choose to put money
in
it's like the cancer cell fighting the
aids cell at this point you know you
know what's better than mmos
gotcha games
everyone's into that lost ark
yeah everyone's into lost i don't know
what it is
i'm too scared to ask i've i've i've
seen a lot of my friends play it on
stream and i'm like okay that looks fun
but
i'm right now i'm into heaven burns red
so i'm explaining that i'm enough for
the story